das Wladimir Putin da seine Finger im
Spiel hatte darf als ziemlich gesichert
gelten sein Quälgeist hat jedenfalls die
Bühne verlassen und hinterlässt
Ungewissheit hat der Tyrann im Kreml
überzogen oder neue Stärke gewonnen
immerhin steht viel aus dem Spiel in der
Ukraine und in Afrika
ins Ende wie steht es um Putins macht
jetzt in der phönix-runde
herzlich Willkommen bei uns meine Gäste
Katrin Eugendorf ist bei uns sie für das
ZDF als internationale Reporterin in
kriegs-
und Krisengebieten unterwegs sind
natürlich auch in Russland der Ukraine
und erwähnen wir natürlich auch dass sie
für ihre Reportagen mit den höchsten
deutschen fernsehpreisen ausgezeichnet
worden sind zugeschaltet aus Innsbruck
ist Professor Gerhard Mangold dort
Politikwissenschaftler an der
Universität und Experte für
internationale Beziehungen und
Sicherheitsforschung im Post zu werden
Raum
Roland Kater ist bei uns
Generalleutnant ist Heeres außer
Diensten sie waren früher deutsche
Vertreter sowohl in den
militärausschüssen der NATO und der des
militärausschusses der NATO und der EU
der militärausschuss der NATO ist die
höchste Kommando Ebene des
nordatlantik-paktes und schließlich
wurde es schumatzki Schriftsteller und
Publizist geboren sind sie in Moskau
leben seit den 1990er Jahren hier in
deutschlandski wie sehen Sie das jetzt
äh trägt dieser Vorfall exakt zwei
Monate nach dem versuchten Marsch auf
moskaufeld das Flugzeug mit mutmaßlich
drin vom Himmel trägt dieser Vorfall
Putins Handschrift eindeutig und das war
ein sozusagen in voraus angekündigte
Mord ich hatte die ganzen zwei Monate
keinen nicht den geringsten Zweifel das
bringt liquidiert werden würde und das
entspricht einfach den
Gesetzen und dementalität diese klicke
jetzt in Russland seine Macht ist
ehrlich gesagt verstehe ich überhaupt
nicht wie man sich dran zweifeln kann
das ist
der Zeitpunkt die Ausführung dieser
ganzen mediale Kampagne drumherum alles
weist eindeutig darauf hin dass es eine
Rache ist die eine demonstrative Rache
zugleich auch ist weil das was die
großen Input ins Auge getan hat ist
unverzeihlich und dafür muss der Zahlen
hat er ja auch alle gekündigt dass er
mit Verrätern keine Gnade kennt dieser
Tod wie immer jetzt zustande gekommen
ist was bedeutet das für Putin
das müssen wir auf verschiedenen eben
sehen also auf der einen Ebene hat das
sicherlich Putin gestärkt weil er hat
sich durchgesetzt
das war sicherlich die größte Bedrohung
und Herausforderung seiner Macht in den
23 Jahren seiner immer weitergehend
totalitär gewordenen Herrschaft
aus dieser Situation ist Putin eindeutig
als Gewinner herausgegangen er hat
gezeigt was passiert mit Leuten die sein
Regime in Frage stellen
auf der anderen Seite ist natürlich
Russland insgesamt geschwächt daraus
gegangen denn diese Situation all das
was pregorian öffentlich gemacht hat
haben uns einen Blicke in das Inneren
eines
desaströsen mafiös organisierten Staates
gezeigt die wir vorher nicht hatten
pregorian gehört ja zu einem der größten
Kritiker auch des ukrainekrieges obwohl
er selbst mit seiner Söldnergruppe
daran beteiligt war und die Tatsache
dass Putin im Prinzip mit einem seiner
engsten Vertrauten auf die Art und Weise
brechen musste und gebrochen hat
zeigt uns in welchem Zustand dieser
Stadt ist ja dieser Einblick dieser
unfreiwillige in die Machtstrukturen ist
ja möglicherweise eine Schwäche des
putinischen Systems jetzt geworden
richtig also deswegen sage ich das kann
man jetzt nicht kann man jetzt nicht man
muss es aus verschiedenen Perspektiven
sehen in politisch und kurzfristig ist
Putin da sicherlich gestärkt
herausgegangen langfristig und was
Russlands globale angeht denke ich ist
Putin und das Regime dass der vertritt
geschwächter herausgegangen Mangold der
Standard in Wien hat er geschrieben der
Putin hätte da der Schlange den Kopf
abgeschlagen und zwar ganz gründlich und
zwar auch deswegen weil ja
hochrangige oder die höchstrangigen
Funktionäre von Wagner
auch in der Maschine saßen also wenn
Putin tatsächlich dahinter steckt haben
sie ihm das ja auch sehr leicht gemacht
was bedeutet das jetzt für die kopflose
Söldnergruppe Wagner für die Zukunft
ich denke dieser Mutwilligkeit
beigeführte Absturz und ich gehe auch
davon aus dass Putin der Auftragsmörder
war der hat Wagner die Gruppe Wagner
enthauptet und es gibt keine natürlichen
Nachfolger der den Status und die
Läufigkeit und das Charisma pregorian
Seite ich glaube aber auch dass
diejenigen bei Wagner die angekündigt
haben sie würden einen zweiten Master
Gerechtigkeit auf Moskau Staaten das war
ja der Name für die Meuterei am 23 juni
die sagen dass aus einer emotionalen
Position heraus aber wir dürfen nicht
vergessen Wagner ist in den letzten zwei
Monaten von der russischen Regierung
weitgehend entwaffnet wurden die
schweren Waffen mussten an das
Verteidigungsministerium zurückgegeben
werden also selbst wenn Partner nicht
führungslos wäre wären sie militärisch
nicht in der Lage das was im Juni
passiert ist noch einmal so wiederholen
er hatte als das noch anders war nämlich
im letzten Winter als
die Wagner sollten das schwer bewaffnet
waren haben sie ja in einer blutigen
Schlacht in der sie fast selbst
aufgerieben worden sind ja bachmut
erobert von der ukrainischen Armee das
was jetzt auch am Mango sagte dass das
quasi eine Macht und Kraft und saftlose
Truppe geworden ist was bedeutet das
eigentlich für den Krieg in der Ukraine
denn bisher hat man ja auch auf Wagner
gesetzt bei diesem Krieg gegen Kiew man
hat ja nicht nur auf Wagner gesetzt und
diese Schlacht um bachmut das war ja
schon eine beeindruckende von Symbolik
von großer Symbolik getragene Schlacht
denn man muss militärisch sehen bachmut
selbst hat bestenfalls eine taktische
Bedeutung einer untergeordnete Bedeutung
aber im Laufe der Monate ist das so
herausragend symbolisch geworden dass
keine Seite auch nur ein Meter
preisgeben wollte das sind exakt die
Fälle wo Truppen wie Wagner und auch
andere eingesetzt werden weil sie
entsprechend hart ausgebildet sind weil
sie entsprechend brutal sind und weil
sie keinerlei Rücksicht nehmen auf
Menschenrechte jedweder Art auch nicht
auf irgendeine Art von Kriegsvölkerrecht
und insofern werden Sie immer dort
eingesetzt jetzt ist das eine andere
Situation ich habe nach wie vor viele
Fragezeichen an der gesamten Operation
aber diese Fragezeichen haben sich
vermutlich deswegen erledigt weil der
Schlange der Kopf abgeschlagen wurde und
was jetzt passiert kann man wirklich nur
spekulieren man kann spekulieren ob der
Rest sich
eingegliedert wird in die russischen
Streitkräfte halte ich für möglich für
Teile aber auch für unwahrscheinlich
einfach weil die russischen Soldaten
schlecht behandelt und B auch schlecht
bezahlt werden und insofern Wagner hat
seine Soldaten ja gut bezahlt also
Krieger seine Soldaten gut bezahlt das
zweite ist diese Aktion damit den in der
letzten Woche ob Lukaschenko sagt oh die
Gelegenheit ist günstig denn das sind
hervorragend ausgebildete Soldaten oder
Freischärler wenn man ehrlich ist auch
ein Großteil jetzt in Belarus glaube ich
stationiert das ist ein Großteil ist
zumindestens dort ob stationiert ja und
da wird man sehen das wäre eine zweite
Möglichkeit und es gibt noch einige
andere
Putin Sprecher die Best of hat ja
jegliche Spekulation zurückgewiesen der
Kreml könnte in den Flugzeugabsturz
verwickelt sein war auch nicht anders zu
erwarten sei eine absolute Lüge also
keine Lüge sondern eine absolute Lüge
heute hat er etwas nachgelegt und gesagt
es können nicht ausgeschlossen werden
dass der Absturz durch eine wörtlich
absichtliche Grausamkeit ausgelöst
worden ist gleichzeitig lehnte Russland
allerdings eine internationale
Untersuchung ab werden wir denn je genau
wissen was da passiert ist
habe ich große Zweifel drin dieser Mord
trägt eindeutig die Handschrift eines
muss man wirklich in aller Härte so
sagen mafiös organisierten Staates also
das ist ja wirklich schon
ja mafia-verfahren im feinsten Stil und
ich glaube dass das Regime ist darauf
anliegt alle Spuren zu verwischen das
ist ja Teil im Prinzip dessen was man
eigentlich damit erzielen will nämlich
Terror und Angst also in einem
demokratisch organisierten Rechtsstaat
hätte ein solcher Putsch gegen gegen
eine Regierung Konsequenzen gehabt dann
wäre nämlich die Putschisten vor Gericht
gestellt worden und hätten einen Prozess
gemacht bekommen das ist hier nicht
geschehen sondern das ist ein ein Mord
der ist trägt einfach Putins Handschrift
ich meine
es ist ja vorher schon von einigen
russischen russischen Regimekritikern
gewarnt worden das pregorien mal
aufpassen und ich glaube in der walnie
hat das unter anderem gesagt dass er
nicht eventuell auch irgendwelche Gifte
in seiner Unterhose findet
einen höheren stockwagen aufhalten
und zu dieser ganzen Strategie des
Terrors gehört natürlich nicht sich dazu
zu bekennen sondern dass alles offen zu
lassen oh mein Gott es gibt ja aber bei
einer solchen Aktion auch immer viele
Mitwisser das muss ja organisiert werden
also wenn wir jetzt mal von dem
wahrscheinlichsten Fall ausgehen dass
der Krimml das eine Hände im Spiel hat
gibt es vielleicht gerade auch bei den
ganzen Gegensätzen innerhalb der
russischen Administration und wo der
eine dem anderen auch kaum etwas gönnt
vielleicht dann doch eine Möglichkeit
dass jemand aus dem nähkästen plaudern
wird eines Tages und sagen kann wie es
wirklich wird oder ist das so
abgeschottet was die
was die das Staatsgeheimnis angeht dass
da nie was rauskommen wird
ich denke eher alle halten Dich
diejenigen die in der Führungsspitze
sind können sich nicht ins Ausland
absetzen sie sind mitverantwortlich für
diesen Krieg und sind dort natürlich
nicht willkommen und sie alle sitzen in
einem Boot und sie brauchen Booten die
Meuterei waren sich ein Schwächezeichen
Putin seine Art Kontrollverlust die er
da erlitten hat und das hat man in der
Führungsriege schon so beobachtet denn
wo die nackt gesagt dieser Verrat wird
unausweichlich bestraft und dann
passierte zwei Monate lang nichts und
Putin kann er sich nicht leisten ich
Schwäche zu zeigen denn wenn er schwach
ist wenn es eine Autorität angezweifelt
wird dann kann er die vielen
rivalisierenden Fraktionen in der
Führung nicht zusammenhalten und
deswegen jetzt diese Tat und er hat
natürlich ausführende Komplizen und auch
Zustimmung in einem innerhalb eines Teil
ist der Führungsriege für diese Tat also
das ist auch ein kollektiver Mord
gewesen
ist ja sehr hemdlich aufgeht sozusagen
Teufelskerl nehme ich mal an kommt ja
auch gut an bei vielen Menschen er hat
ja auch war ja auch durchaus in Russland
hatte ja seine Anhänger und seine
Sympathisanten am Tag dieser Meuterei
oder dieses Marsches auf Moskau ist er
ja freundlich begrüßt worden da in
Rostock am donvoir wo dieser Marsch
losging
wie gibt es denn eine Vermutung darüber
wie diese Meldung über prickosch ins Tod
und auch die Vermutung dass Putin
dahinter steckt bei der russischen
Bevölkerung angekommen ist wie die das
sehen
also ich sage vielleicht zuerst was ich
über Russland gelernt habe
also diese ganzen Geschichte
war dass diese Art von offener
Brutalität und Gewalt die pregorien
verkörpert hat und ausgeübt hat sehr gut
in Russland kommt
erstens bei der Meuterei selber können
wir da stand begeisterte Zuschauer
Applaus sie haben zusammen Lieder
gefunden und
jetzt
haben sich gewisse wenn man in der
Internetsprache sagt memes so kleine
Details ein Teil der russischen Kultur
geworden zum Beispiel der
Vorschlaghammer der Vorschlag kam mit
dem Leute ihre Opfer umgebracht haben
ist wohl wurde neulich von einem glaube
ich russischen ja an seinen Mitarbeiter
übergeben als quasi ein Geschenk als
eine Art Orden und die gibt es auch als
kleine Medaillen zu kaufen kleine
Souvenirs und
das ist etwas waschen erreicht hat wird
er Ihre Frage bei der russischen
Bevölkerung jetzt sehen wir wie gut man
mit der Gewalt dort ankommt und
vielleicht wenn ich darf einen Schritt
zurück
ob funktioniert jetzt als Gewinner
darstellt
oder doch nicht ich glaube in den Augen
von Russen ist der kein Gewinner weil
das was er getan hat und alle wissen
dass er natürlich Groschen umgebracht
hat das was er getan hat war das absolut
mindeste das war keine Heldentat er hat
sich nicht durchgesetzt hat nicht
erreicht er hat wirklich das getan
worauf alles schon lange zwei Monate
lang gewartet haben es gibt ja
wahrscheinlich einige also bei einem
solchen Vorgang den wir jetzt besprechen
mit all den Mysterien und dem Geheimnis
um witterten gibt es ja auch viele
Verschwörungstheorien es gibt ja auch
Menschen die sagen der sei gar nicht tot
er sei sozusagen tot fingiert und ist
jetzt irgendwo untergetaucht sowas auch
denkbar oder ist das muss man das ins
Reich der Fantasie verwandeln das ist
eine reine Spekulation das gehört in
eine Netflix Serie das ist das finde ich
nicht seriös und das ist auch ihre
relevant Hauptsache ist das
und die russische Elite eben gesagt
haben dass bestrafen wir einen Verräter
wird ermordet und das ist das was wir
auch über Russland lernen wichtig das
ist um diese Person Prägungen lebt oder
nicht dass es dann auch egal und wir
werden wahrscheinlich irgendwann
erfahren was was tatsächlich passiert
ist ich meine mit diesen anderen Morden
skripal Liter die sind Vergiftungen mit
einer Wahl nee seine Vergiftung wir
wissen es was dahinter steht wir wissen
was wer das befohlen hat er das alles
gehört hat vielleicht erfahren wir auch
was hinter diesem Motor dahinter steckt
es war ja so dass verschiedene Aufträge
diskrimel ausgeführt also kriegerische
in jetzt in der Ukraine in Afrika ist er
unterwegs er guck mal nachher noch mal
etwas genauer drauf und er war ja
wichtig
durch seine trollfabriken die er in St
Petersburg unterhalten hat also das
Informationskampagnen und das sind ja
auch das Informationskampagne die wir
bis nach Deutschland gereicht haben die
hier zum Teil auch erheblichen Schaden
angerichtet haben möglicherweise noch
anrichten wie ist denn dieses dieser
Geschäftszweig von jetzt aufgestellt hat
er eine Zukunft wird der anders geführt
wer übernimmt den oder verkümmert der
ähnlich wie die militärische Stärke der
Wagner sind
also in dem ganzen Imperium dessen
Vielfalt sie ja gerade beschrieben haben
das pregorien und die wagnertruppe
aufgebaut haben und da gibt es auch
andere seltener Gruppen die daran
beteiligt waren
kann man eine Charakteristik erkennen
das sind nämlich alles die Bereiche zu
denen der russische Staaten nicht stehen
wollte ja also im Prinzip die schmutzige
Arbeit die nicht offiziell gemacht
werden sollte ohne die auf diese diesen
auf dieser Arbeit Fuß das System Putin
ohne diese
Desinformationskampagnen ohne
die Außenpolitik ohne den Krieg in der
Ukraine die gewaltsam macht Erhaltung
von Regime in Afrika kann Russland im
Prinzip als Staat in dieser Form gar
nicht weiter existieren darauf fußt das
System Putin deswegen denke ich wird es
da Umstrukturierungen geben und das hat
man in den letzten zwei Monaten in
Russland auch schon beobachten können
dass das die Elite angefangen hat
bestimmte Umstrukturierungen vorzunehmen
deswegen ich bin mir sicher dass das in
anderer Hände gereicht wird aber ob es
so effektiv organisiert werden kann wie
es von der wagnergruppe organisiert
wurde das wird sich vermutlich so
schnell nicht umsetzen lassen wenn wir
uns diesen 23 Juni noch mal ansehen den
Tag dieses Marsches auf Moskau also
dieser martialisch dieser selbstbewusst
präpotente
aufgetreten ist und die Reaktion von
Putin der dann irgendwie auch angefasst
wirkte in seinem
kreml-palast auch
er hat zwar von Verrat gesprochen aber
es wirkte weitaus weniger überzeugen das
wurde auch als Schwäche empfunden in dem
Moment viele haben diesen Auftritt so
empfunden
auch die die Tatsache dass ja offenbar
die russische Armee überhaupt nicht
eingegriffen hat und sie von begossen
auch noch verhöhnt worden ist als
Gurkentruppe auf gut Deutsch in welchem
Zustand ist denn eigentlich die
russische Armee insgesamt jetzt mit und
ohne Wagner also zunächst mal
schildern sich ja sehr deutlich was
damals zumindest bei mir zu vielen
Fragen geführt hat
die ganze Operation kam für mich muss
ich sagen überraschend zunächst tauchte
er dein restlauf auf es hat mich nicht
überrascht dass er dort mehr oder
weniger freudig empfangen worden ist
denn die Russen und Wagner ich meine das
ist ja eine Seite dann ging dieser
marschlos der dann plötzlich abrupt
gestoppt wurde dann tauchte wie zieht
ihn aus dem Busch Lukaschenko auf und
Boot an ein Frieden oder ein
Waffenstillstand und die Trophäen an da
habe ich noch geglaubt das ganze ist
fake das ganze ist ein das ganze ist ein
Manöver ein Ablenkungsmanöver mit
welchem Ziel auch immer
und eine Zeit lang habe ich sogar
geglaubt
nachdem dann die Truppe nach Belarus
ging sie würden dort eine neuartige
Bedrohung unter Umständen initiieren vom
Norden her auf den Westen der Ukraine
mit dem Ziel Truppen zu binden die an
anderer Stelle gebraucht werden das
andere das ganze ist ich habe da immer
noch Fragen und was die russische
Streitkräfte anbelangt ja die russischen
Streit gehabt haben ja nicht nur Wagner
sondern sie leben ja von vielen dieser
Legionäre oder ja freischaller muss man
sagen die sich an kein Recht und kein
Gesetz halten die auch mit der
entsprechenden Brutalität auftreten das
tun die russischen Soldaten aber auch
was für allgemein feststellen müssen es
schlichtweg dass die russischen Soldaten
also die russische Armee ah schlecht
ausgebildet ist B schlecht behandelt
wird also im Sinne der ich sag mal
einfach wir nennen es innere Führung
aber ich sag mal das mitmenschlichen das
anfangs miteinander das ist ja geradezu
eine Katastrophe glaube ich auch noch
was dazu sagen sie waren ja in der
Einsatz sein darf dass sie natürlich
auch materiell muss man sagen schlecht
ausgestattet sind und ich sag mal die
taktische Leistung die Führungsleistung
der russischen Offiziere ist ja ein
Desaster und das führt genau zu der
Situation in der wir heute sind
unterstützen obwohl ich nicht in der
Armee war aber das sollten sie nicht da
eingezogen werden ja aber ich habe mich
darum gedrückt
ihn falsch in Erinnerung gut okay aber
ja weil das ist ja ein super
interessantes Thema aber jetzt so Ihre
Frage
diese Armee also wir haben auch also den
ganzen Krieg gelernt dass diese
angeblich zwei stärkste der mir der Welt
gar nicht so stark ist erstens das und
zweitens wie ich das jetzt sehe gibt es
keinen großen Unterschied zwischen der
den populären russischen Streitkräften
und diesen privater Arminen der Größe in
der Ausrüstung schon aber was
die Rechtsstaatlichkeit darum geht oder
der Grand de Brutalität das ist alles
ziemlich gleich die schlimmsten
verbrechenden der Ukraine von denen wir
gehört haben Gutschein und so weiter das
waren ganz normale russische Soldaten
und vielleicht noch ein Gedanke dazu
es gibt ja glaube ich jetzt inzwischen
an die 40 kleineren größere privateren
es gibt große Polizei Armeen es gibt
diese rosward der diese Nationalgarde
Putin sind die auch Raketen Waffen hat
und so weiter und so fort und putzen
regiert dieses dieses dieses Schachspiel
diesen Kampf zwischen verschiedenen
Fraktionen
und das was jetzt mit dem priorischen
sputsch passiert ist ist ein großes
Desaster für Putin weil dieses Prinzip
teil und Herrscher hat plötzlich nicht
funktioniert und das ist das Prinzip auf
dem Russland aufgebaut ist
Mangold der Name ist jetzt schon
gefallen Lukaschenko der Machthaber in
Belarus der sich ja als Vermittler an
diesem 23 juni angeboten hat das hat
viele verwundert bisher dachte man
eigentlich dass er immer nur ein Höfling
von Vladimir Putin ist und plötzlich
Dritter ihm in den Augenhöhe gegenüber
und versucht zwischen ihm und und
zu vermitteln es gibt ja auch ein
Gerücht dass
lukaschenkoschen geworden habe vor einem
solchen Anschlag welche Rolle spielt
eigentlich der belarussische Machthaber
in diesem ganzen Kontext
und lukasche hat sich sehr darin
gefallen seine Rolle an diesem Tag der
Meuterei besonders
hochtrabend darzustellen er gesagt Putin
wollte pregorian schon auf dem Weg nach
Moskau liquidieren er habe Putin davon
abgebracht für Putin war es ein Problem
dass
außer der Luftwaffe sich eigentlich kaum
Armeeeinheiten gegen die
vormarschierenden Meuterer gestellt
haben und er musste Zweifel daran haben
ob in der russischen Führung alle gegen
diese mal drei eingestellt sind
wiederum hat sich sehr geehrt er hat
geglaubt es würden in der Führungsriege
in Moskau einige hervortreten und sich
mit ihm verbünden er geglaubt dass Teile
der russischen Armee sich mit ihm
verbinden würden und der ist ja bei
jungen russischen Soldaten sehr beliebt
weil er sich immer für sie eingesetzt
hat er gesagt diese Parkett gewählt
generelle in Moskau wie schön du und der
rassimo auf die verheizen unsere jungen
Männer all diese Erfahrungen auf
sozusagen Abweichler in der Führung und
auf solide Solidarisierungen ist teils
der russischen Armee haben sich nicht
erfüllt und in dieser Situation hat dann
Lukaschenko beiden einen Ausweg geboten
und dieses Exil wurde angeboten Putin
hat auch das Strafverfahren gegen
trikotin sofort einstellen lassen aber
für mich war klar wenn er die Gosche
nicht anfängt in Belarus Rosen zu
züchten und sich nicht mehr äußert dann
wird der liquidiert werden weil Putin
sich das einfach nicht gefallen lassen
konnte ich denke Lukaschenko sagt heute
ein Teil der Wagener Soldaten soll in
Belarus bleiben aber nachdem sie nicht
mehr vom russischen
Verteidigungsministerium bezahlt werden
müsste er sie bezahlen und ich glaube
nicht dass er dazu langfristig in der
Lage ist Freunde
etwas gestärkt worden sogar bis jetzt
hat man ja immer die Vermutung gehabt
irgendwann wird die russische
Förderation Belarus einfach einkassieren
in die Föderation wie das zu
sowjetischen Zeiten schon mal war hat er
sich da ein bisschen Freischwimmen
können von von Putin oder war das nur
war da nur Instrument in diesem Moment
ich sehe lukaschen
Lukaschenko hat es verstanden über viele
viele Jahre sich immer sehr sehr klug
aus der Situation heraus zu lavieren wir
haben ihn erlebt er hat Putin immer
Unterstützung zugesagt weil er auf ihn
angewiesen ist sein Regime steht und
fällt mit dem Regime in Moskau aber er
hat auch immer ganz klar für sich die
Grenzen gezogen also wenn Putin ihn mit
ins Boot holen wollte er ist immer ein
Stück mitgegangen hat aber auch immer
ganz klar gesagt hier sind die Grenzen
denn er weiß natürlich auch wenn er sich
in diesen Krieg in einer Form mit
hineinziehen lassen würde wie Russland
oder Putin das plant dass das auch sein
Untergang wäre weil er braucht sein
Militär und braucht seine im Prinzip
militärischen Kräfte um sein eigenes
Regime zu erhalten deswegen also ich
sehe ihn da nicht als Höfling er ist lu
tschenko versteht es immer sehr sehr
bauernschlau aus den Situationen sich
herauszulavieren und sie dann
letztendlich doch zu seinem Vorteil zu
einzusetzen Putin versucht ja mit seiner
ironen Gewalttätigkeit auch die eigene
Führungsriege davon abzuhalten es
brigoshi nachzumachen jetzt haben wir ja
vorhin sie hat ja gesagt bei dem
Einblick in dieses politische System
mögliche Schwächen gesehen durch diese
Aktion von brikoschin wenn sich da jetzt
der Eindruck festsetzt in dem was sie in
der Entourage von Putin je nachdem wie
sich auch der Krieg weiterentwickelt
wenn einer auf dem Tisch haut und mal
richtig Muskeln zeigt könnte er
möglicherweise tatsächlich zum Erfolg
kommen und Putin auch erfolgreich
Widerstand leisten ist das eine denkbare
an denkbares Szenario wenn man sagt wo
die Frage ist ja auch immer wo könnte
man worüber könnte Putin stürzen oder
ist er absolut sakroisant ist das eine
denkbare Möglichkeit dass jemand sagt
begossen hat uns sozusagen die Blaupause
geliefert muss man ihnen möglicherweise
doch auch ums Eck bringen kann also was
wir ganz sicher gesehen haben ist in der
Situation dass ein Putsch gegen das
Regime oder eine Entmachtung des Regimes
nicht von den Liberalen und Demokraten
zu erwarten ist sondern von rechts
und ich glaube das gefährliche in dieser
Situation für Putin ist dass wenn es
noch einmal zu solch einer Situation
kommt diese Putschisten sicherlich sich
nicht werden durch Verhandlungen
aufhalten lassen weil sie gesehen haben
was passiert dass das passiert ich sehe
dafür im Moment keine Anzeichen aber wir
wissen natürlich auch nicht was in der
russischen Bevölkerung vor sich geht es
gibt Umfrageergebnisse es gibt
Untersuchungen aber im Prinzip ist
Russland seit vielen Jahren hinter einem
eisernen informationsvorhang
verschwunden aber was ganz klar ist es
gibt es brodelt im Land und es brodelt
es gibt eine ganz klare klicke die
möglicherweise auch wachsen könnte ich
halte das mit dem Fall auch das Krieges
in der Ukraine für immer
wahrscheinlicher die Putins macht weiter
in Frage stellen wird sie haben Freunde
ich habe den Eindruck im Augenblick und
das teile ich sehe ich die Gefahr
überhaupt nicht auch militärisch nicht
einfach weil Putin über die Jahre ein
angstregime aufgebaut hat und dieses
angstregime hält Klammer auf noch
Klammer zu das sieht man auch daran um
noch mal auf den Aspekt von innen
aufmerksam zu machen als die Frage kam
warum hat sich diese Marsch nach Norden
eigentlich niemand entgegengestellt wo
war die russische Armee ich glaube die
russische Armee ist dazu nicht in der
Lage und zwar von den von der
Waffentechnik her von den Menschen auch
aber nicht von der Führungsleistung da
eine eigenständige Entscheidung zu
treffen hier brennt es und hier müssen
wir was tun die haben alle zunächst
überrascht und dann haben sie sich
natürlich
gewartet sie haben einfach auf Befehle
gewartet was sollen wir jetzt tun und
als seine Ex kam haben sie nichts getan
die Luftfahrt hat ja dann eingegriffen
klar das geht ja auch relativ schnell
ich will sagen im Augenblick im
Augenblick scheint mir dieses Regime
noch gefestigt zu sein und die Frage ist
wie stark sind die Streitkräfte jetzt in
der Ukraine gebunden
so dass Putin wenn er sie bräuchte im
Inland auf seine eigenen Streitkräfte
zurückgreifen kann gut er hat die
Polizei Armeen er hat die die Söldner
und
also jede Menge noch an an Truppe bzw an
Kampfkraft auch im eigenen Land aber ob
das auf Dauer tatsächlich hält aber
jemand Fragezeichen
ja ich wollte nur sagen ich sehe
eigentlich eine Nachnahme Möglichkeit
oder Optionen in Russland nicht für die
nächsten Monate denn Tatsache ist dass
die Führung des Landes das alle
Mitglieder der Führung Putin braucht
brauchen denn putin ist so eine Art
Vermittler zwischen diesen
rivalisierenden Fraktionen und
schlichtet Streit und lässt alle gut
Leben manchmal setzt sich eine Fraktion
durch manchmal eine andere aber die
Verlierer Fraktion die verliert nicht
völlig sondern sie bekommt dafür
irgendeinen Ausgleich und solange Putin
diese Rolle spielen kann und das ist
durch die autoritätsstärkung jetzt durch
diesen auftragsmarkt sicherlich wieder
leichter geworden wird sich niemand
gegen ihn stellen erst wenn Teil der
Führungsriege das Gefühl haben Putin
kann das nicht mehr leisten hat die
Bevölkerung nicht mehr hinter sich und
wenn sich dann eine Alternative töte
eine personelle dann ist das möglich
aber das halte ich für die nächste Zeit
für absolut ausgeschlossen ich glaube
ein Sturz Putins ist nur denkbar bei
einer desaströsen Kriegsniederlage
Russlands in der Ukraine die entstehen
kann zu der es kommen kann aber eben
nicht mit Gewissheit gilt das wenn man
gut auch für die Personen ramsam kadirov
ja eine weitere Figur in dem
schauerlichen russischen Auftreten auf
dem Schlachtfeld das Land ist nicht arm
an Bluthunden dazu gehört er in aller
erster Linie mit dazu ähm er hat ja auch
eine Art privat Armee im Dienste des
Kreml würde von dieser Seite auch
gefragt drohen können
das ist die Gruppe Ahmad die zum Teil
auch in der Ukraine gekämpft hat aber
nicht so erfolgreich und so entschlossen
wie die Gruppe Wagner aber Kartierung
ist gewissermaßen der Zögling Putins und
baue beide brauchen einander
gegeben was er in den 2000er Jahren
gebraucht hat nämlich eine Beilegung des
Unabhängigkeitskampfes und auch der
islamistischen Kämpfer die einem Rad
angestrebt haben im nordkasus durch
tschetschenische Kämpfer die von kadiro
finanziert wurden und diese aufstehende
niedergeschlagen haben das hat kadiro
verputin geleistet und umgekehrt hat
Putin Kadir auf unter Republik
Tschetschenien Unmengen an Geld zu Gute
kommen lassen zur persönlichen
Bereicherung von Kadir auf aber auch zum
wieder Aufbau von Tschetschenien und das
hat akadiros Schreckensherrschaft in
Tschetschenien schon nach ein Stück weit
gestärkt für eine gewisse Zeit weil er
unter ihm dieses Land dieses Kriegs was
der genannt wieder aufgebaut wurde also
beide Seiten brauchen einander beide
sind unabhängig voneinander nicht
denkbar ich glaube nicht dass von
Gradierung eine Gefahr ausgeht und
gegenkatiere gibt es ebenfalls in der
Moskau Führungsriege sehr viele die
sein zu tun nicht gutheißen das ist vor
allem der Inlandsgeheimdienst FSB der
nahezu eine schon jahrzehntelange
Feindschaft mit kg austreten
Szenario skizziert über die inneren
Verhältnisse in Russland sie haben
glaube ich mal gesagt die russische
Sprache ist eigentlich die Sprache der
Gewalt also sie ist quasi die ID oder
nicht die die DNA der der russische
Sprache ist Gewalt und das Wort Frieden
spielt in dieser Sprache überhaupt keine
Rolle das sind nimmt man zwar wahr aber
es wird als Schwäche empfunden von
anderen und provoziert auf diese Leute
einzuschlagen die eigentlich Frieden
wollen wohin führt diese Entwicklung
eigentlich die russische Gesellschaft
die sich immer mehr isoliert jetzt auch
durch diesen Krieg und die eigentlich ja
dadurch auch wenn ich sie jetzt richtig
verstehe niemals verhandlungs- und
fraktionsfähig ist um zum Beispiel den
Krieg gegen die Ukraine zu beenden und
mit dem besten wieder in friedlicher
Nachbarschaft zu leben durch
Verhandlungen ich
glaube natürlich nicht dass die
russische Sprache per se
hat gewaltsprache ist es gibt aber
innerhalb des russischen eine Sprache
des der Gewalt das russische der Gewalt
sage ich dazu und das ist die Sprache
Potenz und pregorians und diese Sprache
regiert jetzt im Lande ich wo will das
einfach so umdrehen das ist wichtig und
mit diesen Menschen ist es
für uns aus der demokratischen
Perspektive sehr schwierig und fast
unmöglich zu verhandeln weil jeder
Versuch
einfach ein Appell zu verhandeln wird
als schwächer wahrgenommen und diese
Schwäche bedeutet für den für die
russische Seite du musst angreifen das
passiert was reflexartig das heißt um
überhaupt verhandeln zu können
sollte man die eigene Machtposition und
Gewaltbereitschaft aufbauen und die
eigene Gewaltbereitschaft demonstrieren
was uns allen hier nicht leicht fällt
aber das ist der einzige Möglichkeit
einen Frieden zu reichen und ich wollte
vielleicht wenn wir schon wieder Zukunft
reden ein wir den Schritt zurück machen
zum Thema
was das für die Zukunft Russland
bedeutet
für mich ist es eine Art Vorahnung des
Bürgerkrieges
ich stimme Ihnen zu in den nächsten
Monaten wird wahrscheinlich nichts
passieren wir wissen nicht wie lange
dieses System von dem wir hier
gesprochen haben mit den realisierenden
Clans und Interessensgruppen mit 40
privater Armeen und unterschiedlichen
Streitkräften wie lange das System
überhaupt stabil bleiben kann dieses
System ist an und für sich instabil und
dieses System können 20 Wochen
zusammenbrechen oder in 20 Jahren auch
zusammenbrechen wird es
wenn wir das jetzt ansehen was in
Russland gerade passiert was Putin tut
hat man ja vielleicht manchmal auch das
Gefühl er könne seine Instrumente seine
Macht Optionen auch das Wasser in der
Hand hat an materiellen um Macht zu
erhalten über denen wie sieht's damit
seinen Aktivitäten in Afrika eigentlich
auch Eigendorf das ist ja man Putin
versucht seine Macht der politischen
militärisch vor allem auch
wirtschaftlich gerade durch seine Afrika
Aktivitäten
quasi abzusichern da stiftet er viel
Unruhe in West- und Zentralafrika er hat
sich ja da auch als Koalitionspartner
beim Russland afrika-gipfel Angeboten in
St Petersburg macht er sich da etwas vor
oder ist das nach wie vor eine echte
Machtoption die er hat das ist natürlich
Teil seiner globalen Strategie also
russland will auf der Weltbühne global
gerade in den Ländern der Dritten Welt
eine zunehmende Rolle spielen und spielt
natürlich vor allem mit diesem
Argumentationsmuster dass er die
westlichen Länder im Prinzip diese
länderkolonialisiert haben das sieht man
auch in Lateinamerika ist das ein
wichtiges Argument in Afrika hat die
wagnertruppe und auch andere seltener
Truppen auf wirklich kriminellste und
schlimmste Art und Weise
Diktaturen abgesichert und im im
Gegenzug dafür Zugang zu Rohstoffen
bekommen ich glaube das Putin sich auf
Dauer auf all diesen vielen Krieg
komplexen droht zu verheben wir sehen
der Ukraine Krieg das ist sein
eklatantes da Fehler gewesen in seiner
gesamten Amtszeit er wird diesen Krieg
nicht gewinnen können wenn man das
Kriegsziel nimmt was er sich selber
gesetzt hat die Ukraine einzunehmen wie
lange dieser Krieg noch dauern wird das
ist im Moment nicht klar aber was klar
ist Russland wird an diesem Krieg immer
weiter und weiter innen von innen
zerbrechen und ich sehe dieses Szenario
das
die Kräfte im Land derer Putin sich
bedient also diese gewaltkräfte von
denen sie auch sprechen ja also ich
nenne das immer so die gulagfraktion das
ist ja im Prinzip auch der Hintergrund
aus dem pregorian kommt ja die wird an
Gewicht gewinnen putin ist ja jemand der
seine Macht versucht hat dadurch
abzusichern und diese Sprache der Gewalt
diese Kultur der Gewalt wird immer mehr
an Bedeutung gewinnen und wir sehen ja
jetzt schon dass junge Russen die das
Vertreten für die ist schon ein Held und
wir sehen ja auch den Erfolg denn ich
meine was Wagner dort in Afrika in der
Sahelzone bewirkt hat das ist ja schon
mal beeindruckend ein Staat nach dem
anderen verfällt ein Staat nach dem
anderen
es kommt zur Revolution und im Ergebnis
wird die Bundeswehr dort abziehen in
Mali und zwar sehr schnell also nicht
wie geplant bis zum nächsten Jahr
sondern noch bis Ende dieses Jahres wird
die Bundeswehr aus Afrika verschwunden
sein das mag man aus militärischen
Gründen mag man das in diesem Augenblick
für richtig halten aber politisch
gesehen halte ich für eine Katastrophe
dass der Westen im Grunde genommen dort
kapitulieren muss und ähnlich wie bei
der
Domino Theorie in 1960er Jahren in
Südostasien Vietnamkrieg da wurde ja
auch gesagt wenn das eine Landfeld will
das nächste gleich mit im Prinzip hat er
das ja schon fast vollzogen deshalb hat
ja fast nahezu wenn ich das richtig
übersehe alle Staaten in Zentral und
Westafrika auf seiner Seite einzige
Frage die sich mir stellt als
Staatsbürger ist die inwieweit wird
China das Zulassen inwie weit China
seinen Einfluss auch ähm einbringen
wollen in China ist ja auch massiv in
der gerade in der hölzone noch und der
wirtschaftlichen Aspekten im Einsatz
aber wie sich das entwickelt da bin ich
schon in Sorge das muss ich sagen mein
Gott diese Rivalität die sich da
möglicherweise in der Dritten Welt
Auftritt zwischen China und Russland
selbst wenn Sie versuchen innerhalb des
blicksystems zusammenzuarbeiten ist das
etwas was Putin auch richtig bedroht
denn so wie man die Sache sieht ist er
da ja eindeutig die Nummer 2
es gibt so eine Art Arbeitsteil langen
Zentralafrika zwischen China und
Russland Russland kann er nichts
anbieten Investitionen Ausweitung des
Handels dazu ist Russland finanziell
viel zu schwach was Russland anbietet
sind Sicherheitsgarantien für mehr oder
weniger autoritäre Herrscher und diese
Garantien werden im umgesetzt durch
Wagner in Zukunft werden das
wahrscheinlich Söldner der Gruppe reduz
sein eine von Gnade dienschenko auch ein
Putin künstling finanziertes privates
militär-chor und das ist das was
Russland dort leistet Kinder
konzentriert sich in dieser Region das
was es sehr viel besser kann als
Russland darauf hier wirtschaftlich und
finanziell sich zu engagieren in der
Infrastruktur sich zu engagieren und
damit politischen Einfluss zu lassen zu
erhalten also Russland erledigt dort die
Drecksarbeit die autoritieren Herrscher
an der Macht zu halten und China macht
mit diesen Herrschern dann gute
Geschenke also wenn ich das Gespräch
jetzt heute Abend mal zusammenfasse hat
Russland und hat Putin aufgrund eigener
Zwänge aber auch eigene Überzeugungen
und eigener Ziele überhaupt kein
Interesse den Krieg in der Ukraine gegen
die Ukraine diesen Überfall auf die
Ukraine in absehbarer Zeit zu beenden
nein nein
eindeutig nein weil er hat das Überleben
seines Regimes an diesen Krieg in der
Ukraine und an einen von ihm
konzipierten Sieg
geknüpft und ich glaube
das mit Putin kein Frieden zu erreichen
ist also ich sehe dafür im Moment
überhaupt gar keine Perspektive ich
meine wir können nicht in die Zukunft
gucken Dinge können sich verändern aber
zur aktuellen Situation definitiv nein
wer nutzt ab in diesem Krieg also im
Augenblick leider beide deswegen kommt
es massiv darauf an dass wir jetzt mit
allen Mitteln die Ukraine unterstützen
im humanitär wirtschaftlich aber auch
militärisch mit allem was sie braucht
und das nach Möglichkeit schnell ich
sehe natürlich hier Grenzen weil einfach
ein paar Rahmenbedingungen die dauern
also Ausbildung dauert das Material
bereitzustellen dauert nach einer
Entscheidung aber wir müssen uns beeilen
denn die Zeit drängt wir haben noch
sechs Wochen in diesem Jahr dann kommt
diese oder rasputitia die setzt
sich im nächsten Frühjahr fort also ich
bin sicher wir werden im nächsten
Frühjahr den Krieg noch erleben putin
wird das freuen denn ich glaube mit
einem Auge schielt er auf die
amerikanischen Wahlen zumindest auf die
Vorwahlen weil er sich von dort
natürlich Unterstützung erhofft und wenn
ich heute Viktor Orban höre dann muss
ich nur sagen oh ähm achtung wir haben
nur noch eine Minute Zeit Schmerz geht
das heißt die russische Gesellschaft
steht bei all dem bei Seite weil sie
sich nicht äußern kann nicht äußern darf
vielleicht auch nicht äußern und Ihre
Wünsche ihre Vorstellungen von einer
gerechten und guten Zukunft gar nicht
einbringen kann ich glaube eher weil die
russische Gesellschaft sich von dieser
Gewalt von dieser gewaltsprache und
Gewalt tatsächlich aus Ägypten Gewalt
leider angesprochen fühlt das ist sehr
tragisch aber das ist das ist leider die
wahre dass wir auch in diesen letzten
zwei Jahren gelernt haben und zum Thema
buten weg und dann haben wir den Frieden
ich glaube nicht ich glaube der Frieden
kommt erst wenn Russland einen
Niederlage erleidet nur in dem Fall
haben wir den Frieden
das könnte ja auch noch lange dauern je
nachdem wie auch dieser Krieg ausgeht
Niederlage ist auch eine
Definitionsfrage auf jeden Fall ein
Thema das uns leider noch lange erhalten
bleiben wird ich bedanke mich bei Katrin
Eugendorf bei Boris schumatzki bei
Roland Kater und bei Gerd Mangold aus
zugeschaltet aus Innsbruck Liebe
ZuschauerInnen liebe Zuschauer morgen in
der Phönix Runde klar im Wahlkampf der
Fall einwanger
aktuelles bei Phoenix der Tag mit Ines
Arland darin auch die Ergebnisse der
koalitionsklausur in Meseberg bleiben
Sie bei uns
[Musik]